The question is,
would you like to contribute to the price pool?
If so,
please do it.
Now.
I'm willing to contribute.
I'll put up another $750 I'll make it $1,000
are you kidding me?
You're serious?
Yes.
Hundred
Boring.
Here we go.
My name is deandre coats and I work at University of Southern California,
USC,
and I work in residence life,
student affairs.
Oh,
my name is a niche.
I work at a health care startup as a medical scribe trainer.
Oh my God.
This is Romania.
I'm just Lezama.
I'm a youtuber and blogger.
I've been doing it since before.
Youtube was a thing since 2009 so,
oh gee.
Youtube in the house.
I'll take,
my name is Mike McCabe.
I'm in real estate and marketing.
I love what I do.
I'm very good at what I do.
And uh,
that's my calling in life.
I found it.
I guess I'm blessed for that.
Oh,
doubles Janet.
That's chance.
Yeah.
So how much would you chop off a limb for?
$40 million.
What makes you feel better?
Just a shot in the dark because that means that I'd be able to get that
prosthetic prosthetically put back on and I also would have a piece of mind
because I did this for no less than 48 hours.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to go and say 42 million.
I would say 100 million because I mean I'm a strong girl and my legs are strong.
Whoever's getting this left leg squat for days.
Yeah.
I would never chop up any lymph,
any amount of money.
I would,
however,
chop off anybody pod for someone I loved.
It's a cop out of God,
but I read the question,
answer then I,
okay.
Connecticut.
What was the most financially desperate time of your life?
How did you deal with it?
Oh,
they were so many.
I was a teen mom.
Single mom,
you apparently you cannot sleep in a Walmart parking lot in a car with your
baby.
So that was me and a wow.
I'm still here so it's all good.
But a,
yeah,
good stories in college there it was one semester where I could not afford to go
back.
I like applied for Shit,
ton of scholarships and I got one.
I'm really fortunate to have grown up and a well off family.
My parents did a lot of the hard work,
them being immigrants and the fact that my parents are incredibly supportive.
I have not encountered yet
and I hope I don't.
But yeah,
very blessed.
When I was a kid we had,
uh,
we would,
um,
upper middle class and then my dad went bankrupt.
I moved to America at 15 and a half by myself living on my grandmother's floor
and my father moved to Africa and so he was trying to send money and I remember
talking to my dad and I said,
what's up?
Where's the money?
You've got to pay the rent.
He said,
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
And then you realize,
oh shit.
Well not all shit.
No fight or flight kind of happens.
And that's when your persona as a human,
you resilience comes out.
But it was the best thing that ever happened to me.
Good.
Yeah.
Super,
super great.
Oh,
I gotta pay you.
Yeah,
Devede they have to pay you.
Okay,
Paul,
I'm funny.
I love being great.
Where were you?
Can money solve the world's problems?
Hails to the no,
no,
no.
I disagree with that wholeheartedly.
Yes.
Again,
I don't think so.
Why do you disagree?
I just do.
I think,
I think money can not fix anything
in a capitalistic societies such as we have.
I feel like money equals power and so like if you don't have it,
I think you don't have a say in the room and a lot of ways and so I think it
can't fix things holistically,
but it can change status,
which I think changes things
I'm going to stick to.
It fixes problems to a certain point.
It's,
I agree with that.
Great.
It's like to a certain point and like you know,
the more money you have,
the more financial secure you are,
blah,
Blah Blah and your happiness.
You have more options.
But then after a point you know your happiness.
I believe plateaus.
After you make a certain amount of money,
the more money you make that doesn't have any correlation or any day money is
not going to make you happier not to begin with.
The end of it.
What?
The answer?
The original question,
which was does money?
Yes.
It solves many,
many problems.
There's certain problems that cannot be solved with money,
but 80% of your day to day issues revolve around money.
Money solves some problems with it doesn't solve everything.
It's what we're saying.
Yeah.
It gives you the resources and potential,
but it's not a done deal.
Answer this question or pay $100 to the bank.
If you don't answer this question,
how much do you make?
And my previous job,
I made 20 an hour.
I Made 47 K I bid on a bellows,
add a lot of brand deals.
Last year I made
FY one $253,
which I probably will because I'm going to beat everybody.
I've been into solo traveling recently,
so I'd probably take that 250 bucks,
get an airfare ticket.
I have tried to be better with saving.
Um,
so 250 it doesn't sound like a whole lot at the moment,
but I think if I got it,
I'd try to
save some of it.
I'm probably going to spread the wealth and give my portions to everybody else
or invite everybody to a nice meal.
That's probably what I'm going to do with that money.
If I went,
if I went $250 a day,
I would donate it to my favorites nonprofit organization,
which is the thirst project,
so I'm going to win it for them.
Oh,
rent $8 yeah.
This is very different with real money.
This is like changing how partner and give you that.
Okay.
The question is would you like to contribute to the price?
Paul?
If so,
please do it now.
So this will be going to one of you.
If we want mines for charity,
what does like charity of your own pocket?
If there's a project I'm willing to contribute but I don't have cash,
I'll put up to another $750 I'm making $1,000 are you kidding?
You're serious.
So whoever wins,
you're just going to Venmo them $750 seriously on it.
Third hand shake on it and make sure he's not.
No,
I think it might be the liquid courage.
Shocking.
Yeah.
Is capitalism good?
I don't think it's perfect,
but I don't think there is a perfect system.
You'll never please everybody.
I do think,
um,
because I've been in bread and like born into a capitalistic system,
I'm programmed to think my worth and value is attributed to like how much I have
or how much I can spend on this thing.
And so I don't love that in your head.
Yeah,
I don't think of it.
That's why it's so funny.
I think of it does,
uh,
I create my destiny.
There's no captain my ability that you want to attain that and that you can
attain that Dow.
Sorry.
I feel like you create your own destiny and where until you don't though.
That's true.
But then that's your choice,
don't you think?
I think we don't always have a choice in a lot of ways.
So like we don't,
we can't control where we're born or who were born too.
Um,
and so I think the whole bootstrap pulling yourself up from your bootstraps.
Some people don't have a boot to pull their shops up with.
Do you think some people lack motivation to change their circumstances?
So you use the analogy of you were a teen mom and and like you worked and you
fought,
you did all these things.
I know other teen moms who also,
I know personally their support,
their effort.
Yeah.
So I think they had support from their families and then I was kicked out.
So yeah.
So they had support from the friends and still still didn't make it though.
Did like are struggling right now.
So people gave up?
No,
no.
There's still some saying there's still fighting,
but there are circumstances aren't changing and that's not anything that they're
doing.
You've got to stop.
I have to stop.
If you keep doing the same thing.
So if you were
four children and you get help from your family,
but you still aren't,
you're circumstances aren't changing.
You're telling me that that's their fault.
100% okay.
200 oh you're so lucky.
Community chest.
Thank you.
I get this.
No,
not only get better at this.
I'm going to get this,
roll the dice.
The highest roller may dare the others to do anything to get out of a dare.
Pay $125 to the bank.
I see you.
All right,
so the dairies,
so I dare you to tell everyone your how much you make.
It's millions of millions of dollars.
Hey,
exactly the exact number,
but the honest truth is I don't even know really.
I don't know exactly how a Jamaica,
I know it's millions of dollars.
Okay?
I dare you to throw all of your money up in the air.
How much is it?
Declare it.
89 bucks.
Okay.
Yeah,
that was beautiful.
That makes sure you kick it off and that you don't lose any money.
Yeah,
no ship you over $400 or $450 for 50 alright,
here we go.
So I'm going to have to pay you the rest.
He was supposed to mortgage your house or a property.
That's how you lose.
Okay.
This is the beginning of your downfall.
It looks like it is.
I'm going to mortgage waterworks.
How much is that?
what's something money can't buy that.
Great.
Even though I said that earlier,
you can buy health money,
can't buy you love it,
can't buy you happiness,
which we've all there.
You said so any of these things can be yeah,
no whammies
no,
I knew there and that's what happens when the university is like boom,
I'll give it to you.
There's a book,
Law of attraction secret.
You can't even put it out.
And then the kid is the 600 buck one.
Okay.
And his defense though.
I did like say that multiple times in my mind and I still haven't gotten pretty
Clark.
Really believe it.
I did
six six.
Are you kidding me?
Oh you got it.
Good job.
Truly believed that I asked you.
Did you truly believe it?
I did.
Boom baby I fucking told you is true.
How did your parents or guardians influence how you think about money or
success?
Because they kicked me out.
I had to make it happen.
And I think when you're put in a situation again with the fight or flight,
I would hope most people would fight.
Um,
and that's what I did.
And I think that's what made me the person I am today.
Had they given me every,
all the resources I needed to be.
Okay.
I don't know that I would be this person.
I don't know.
What do you mean you definitely would not be this person.
I'm telling you this,
you'd be maybe,
I don't know.
I feel very,
very,
very
driven.
And you're also the tenacity that you have originally in your personality.
I can tell you are tenacious person,
but I think 100% without even knowing you for too long,
you are who you are because you suffered and you did what you did to get to this
point.
You're absolutely fine.
Can I just say one thing,
which is like,
you know,
all three of you.
I feel like it,
you know,
I'd be like clearly struggled a lot more than I have in like that's something
that I can't relate to.
And usually I used to feel bad just because like that's how it can make you
feel.
And I think now in the last couple of years,
I've come to the realization that,
you know,
just because you may have not had those type of struggles,
like financially,
um,
you shouldn't feel bad.
You should not,
you know,
you have those like moments where you like reappeared and eyes.
I don't even know if that's a word,
but like that's like I've had like a reappear.
Funny on that.
Even though I've realized a while ago that I shouldn't feel bad.
Oh yeah.
So good.
Okay.
Four 39 cause some number that for me,
$918 in cash.
Wait,
wait.
Even with all your property,
you haven't counted the property.
1000,
145.
How would you guys,
uh,
five oh nine.
Good job.
Good game.
That was fun.
Low One.
I have a better idea why you guys choose,
because I was going to give all the money between all of you.
Oh.
Or You could just give all the money to her for a charity.
Take the to 50th start there.
Then I'll add to the pot.
$50 maybe $250 a charity.
Got to add the other Ryko was generous.
Oh yeah.
He's been wearing it right now.
Your dollars can equal $1,000 going,
Yay.
We just gave 40 people clean drinking water for life.
We just gave a 40 keep all clean drinking water for life,
for life.
Wow.